Democrat Republican oh really okay well
then you tell me I disagree I do
disagree I think it's really detrimental
to a country where you block freedom of
the press from disagreeing with the
president it's better to have these
disagreeing publications so that we hear
this other side I completely agree with
everything you just said that's why I
think calling in fake news is a bad
thing but they are fake news okay time
for the latest installment of changed my
mind where we rationalize our positions
on controversial issues for this episode
I set up shop outside CNN headquarters
in Washington DC to discuss why I
believe that CNN is fake news funnily
enough we actually ended up having more
conservatives sit down than liberals who
tried to argue the other side we like
and I agree the Flexi and that's better
okay second do you really disagree or
I'm conservative and I have watching so
for a long time a lot of that nothing
would confirm today
you disagree no really I would like to
talk ups well which kind of surprised me
maybe not too many people actually
disagree with the premise so what do you
think is CNN a legitimate unbiased
network of journalism or is it merely
fake news masquerading as such comment
below let me know but first up meet
Christine no pressure
[Applause]
nice to meet you I'm Stevie Christine
nice to meet you
so you work next to see it you work next
to see I do arrogance
you work at the Department of Education
um well I I work for a private
corporation that's working for the
Department of Education okay all right
you don't have to tell me I don't mean
it fryer today but you said you kind of
liked CNN so yeah today's topic is uh
listen I think CNN is fake news not real
not a legitimate news outlet I know a
lot of people a lot of people disagree
with me I'm not convinced but you're
more than welcome to tape in mind or we
can just talk about it in this case does
it sound like you weren't sure well I
think every news network whether it be
CNN or Fox News has it their own biases
sure um I think that I think what you're
referring to is the events that happened
yesterday well what do you mean no I'm
not referring to just specific events
from yesterday but what are you
referring to um well I think you're
insinuating
about the the shootings that happened
yesterday and how you know the news
media may be biased regarding their
coverage well they definitely are but no
that's not what I'm talking about
well I think overall every news media
outlet has their own biases I think that
that's not necessarily a bad thing
that's protected you know CNN might say
things that people disagree with and
that might cause some uproars and Fox
News does as well and I think that
applies to every news network but but I
would say the primary difference between
you know Fox News and MSNBC and Fox News
to be fair to them they do have a news
division but people like Shawn have any
Tucker Carlson our opinion as well as
Rachel Maddow Chris Hayes Versailles
Chris Matthews you know where they line
up right there being forthcoming about
the fact that they're hotbeds men the
scene interest itself is actual news but
that's my issue I think you're right
they do have a bias I think we both
agree but they claim that they don't
they claim it straight down the middle
news my issue with the dishonesty is the
misleading the American public as those
as unbiased news especially when CNN has
been caught fabricating so many stories
Finnair that people unfortunately many
of them many people still believe oh
what do you mean by fabricated I can
even provide a pose yeah I mean make
them up like but most of the Russia
stories right like for example I mean
the Donald Trump feeding on prostitutes
made up the idea that Donald Trump got
information from WikiLeaks beforehand I
don't know if you still believe that
made up matter attractive the idea that
Donald Trump knew about the Trump Tower
meetings beforehand they said it was a
not as Senate an anonymous source and
then said Lonny Davis declined to
comment the source was Lonny Davis the
idea that da wall they called Donald
Trump a liar when he said James Comey
told them he wasn't under investigation
turns out James Comey said that three
times they were the ones who pushed the
fusion GPS the steel dossier you know
the whole Russia collusion is pushed by
the steel dossier that was paid for by
the DNC in by Hillary Clinton who did
work with the Russians to try and do our
research so a time after time after time
and of course now it's been proven they
didn't collude with the Russians but you
have 48 percent of Americans who do and
an even greater percentage of Americans
who believe a lot of these verifiably
false stories that came exclusively from
CNN that's my issue I don't have an
issue with someone going up there saying
hey I have an opinion I don't like the
president I have an issue with people
claiming that they're journalists but
lying to mislead the American
well I think when those reporters
happened a lot of the information
available was ambiguous so people were
reporting on things that were bias and
that I think that applies again to all
networks but I don't think it was
necessarily libel or slander because
there wasn't enough evidence at the time
so it may be that the evidence came
exclusively from CNN it was proven to be
false no that's my issue
CNN BuzzFeed worst offender but we don't
need to get into BuzzFeed no one really
cares about them anyway but they work
together quite a bit collude that's a
very popular term these days so when CNN
is the source that is amplified in the
Washington Post and it's verifiably
Falls we have to retract it but the
damage is done that's happened so many
times and I could understand getting
stories wrong right that happened
everybody got stories wrong but how is
it possible that every story they get
wrong was pushing a narrative to
undermine the legitimacy of a sitting
president
I mean wouldn't they occasionally get it
wrong going the other way right well I
mean collusion is a pretty serious thing
your ends I know that these Hillary
Clinton did it and they never talked
about it well I mean it it's just as
serious no matter who's doing it no
matter what party but they knew that
fusion GPS the dossier was paper by DNC
and doing equipment they knew that and
they tried it they knew the Hilton went
to opposition try and do Apple research
they knew that and they obvious cater
that right it's serious if anyone does
it so why is it always in one direction
when these fabricated stories with their
sources who are anonymous and exclusive
to CNN always line up to paint Donald
Trump to be
in a legitimate president well I don't
think that they purposefully are
presenting false statements I think that
when they reported on those things they
believed that those things were
happening and again some of these things
are still developing so if someone
reported something one day and then
there's new evidence another day that
doesn't mean that that was a false
narrative it just means that there may
there most likely is bias involved but
they were working off in a biggest
situation and everybody knows that
especially with higher office politics
there are back office things but you
don't think there's a pattern CN n of
being far left and obfuscating you don't
it's not just what they choose to make
up also within choose not to cover right
like Brett Kavanaugh or that information
that they knew verifiably some of the
rape accusations for example Julie sweat
Nick were false but they could not be
corroborated as a matter of fact they
were refuted by other people's stories
and they decided to hold it until after
the hearing but go forward with the
forward information for testimony which
they also knew there were some
inconsistencies there which they
withheld so it's not just what they push
forward that's false but the information
they withhold if they know it'll be
politically damaging you don't think the
CNN does that happen what would it take
for you to believe that CNN is more
left-leaning I guess politically biased
I think that they do lien loves but I
don't necessarily think that thumb being
laughs and engaging in their
professional activities which is
reporting the news I don't think that
that's wrong and the reason why I don't
think that's wrong is because whether or
not you love left-leaning media or you
hate left-leaning me it's the freedom of
speech I support of course freedom of
speech and freedom of the press and I
assume that you do - across the board
any speech on campus everywhere right
which I appreciate cuz many people on
the Left don't see an end of them
support freedom of speech certainly if
you look at turn around no they don't
they've tried to shut down our channel
multiple times not only for false
copyright but for speech issues that
they find offensive so does NBC so I
appreciate that you support
I appreciate you support freedom of
speech but you said you do think CNN
leans left and that they're doing their
job presenting the news let me ask you
this
Fox News is pretty straightforward about
that everyone knows their conservative
MSNBC is very straightforward at their
left would you say CNN is
straightforward that they're left
because he just admitted they are do you
think they're forthcoming about their
leftist bias or do they present
themselves as mainstream online news I
mean I think they're just as transparent
as Fox News really yeah you think CNN
markets itself as a left-wing news
source well the reason why I think Fox
News markets itself as a right-leaning
because the only one but yeah because
there's such a minority right so I think
it's a marketing tactic and I think that
everybody knows that the media and CNN
are
and so I don't think it's something that
they feel they need to highlight because
it's just concentration when like Chris
Cuomo goes out and says no no I'm just
I'm just getting to the facts I'm a
journalist where we know that's not the
case or like a Don Lemon as someone
who's been the victim of some of these
smear campaigns I would just appreciate
if there are forthcoming about their
views but how many false stories would
take I mean is Russia not enough right
now the fact that Donald Trump is
included with the Russian was is that
not a big enough we got that wrong like
Casilla name was that the forefront
pushing all those stories which turned
out to be false well we're not sure what
they're not sure we are well why don't
you believe that because there isn't
enough
we have evidence yeah no collusion with
Russia there been no charges she's not
guilty these things are very high
intelligence if if there was collusion
it's off record no it would be
completely on the record that's why
there was an investigation I don't think
if people who wanted to put Trump away
people like Muller there's no there's no
evidence of collusion and the evidence
of collusion that we thought existed was
proven verifiably false because it came
all the way from circle back now CNN not
a big enough deal like claiming that our
president is a foreign agent with
multiple specific examples of stories
that they subsequently had to retract
that were verifiably false I mean what
more than that would it take to say okay
maybe CNN is has a bias that they're not
forthcoming about well do you think if
there was collusion that it would have
been done off record with the
expectation that the FBI and
higher-level intelligence would be going
through the logistics I'm FBI and these
people especially you're talking about
fifty million dollars in taxpayer
dollars and you're talking about
hundreds of federal agents who've been
investigating us I think they have a
ways to get into what was off the record
you know they assumed it would be off
the record they don't think they think
that Donald Trump is gonna hey Putin you
want to rig the election flubby thinks
you know that's not what happens there's
a thorough investigation frankly I'm
amazed they found as little as they did
which was nothing that's amazing to me
I mean if you were audited or I were
audited you're putting the cuffs on us
you can audit a ham sandwich and send
him to jail well we don't have access to
higher intelligence officials sure yeah
we don't they didn't say there was no
collusion so I'm just curious as to why
you still believe that could it be
because of all the stories that have
been drip drip drip drip from places
like CNN that maybe it's gotten into
your subconscious and you believe some
of these things no I mean it's possible
anything is possible
yeah but I personally I mean I'm a
Democrat but I'm very Pro free speech
and I try to understand both sides of
the aisle and sometimes I you know
listen to Fox News just to understand
the other side and you know I don't I
don't know what how about the collusion
I I think it may have happened but I
don't believe that it didn't only
because of previous things that have
happened
in the government like what I just want
those things where you can say like if
someone accuses somebody of being a
foreign agent right there needs to be
some kind of proof why do you believe it
well I don't think that he's a foreign
agent okay why do you we working with
Russia during the election I think that
those things would be off record okay
and you don't think the FBI would get to
get to that you don't think a special
prosecutor fifty million dollars would
be able to find anything we were able to
find that the stories we thought were
true or false was CNN right we were able
to discover that that he didn't know
about the meeting with Trump Towers
beforehand that James Comey did tell him
he wasn't being investigative they
didn't get info from WikiLeaks so we
were able to verify that all things that
came from CNN was for false I mean that
took a lot of digging but you don't
think that they would be able to find
actual collusion of existed
I mean I don't know because
again I think that if anything happened
it would be off record the same thing
that Christine we say for a situation I
think that it may have happened to me
not but it's nothing that she said was
consistent again that goes back to CNN
she gave a story to the shrink which did
not correspond with the story that was
given to Washington Post
she gave information to the police that
couldn't have possibly been possible how
is it that name the house it wasn't
there no place with that kind of a floor
plan the dates didn't match up nothing
matched up nothing was consistent and I
do think that listen rape is one of the
worst crime someone can commit but it's
really bad to falsely accuse someone but
she did say that it occurred many
decades ago and she has trauma so her
breakfast recollections do you think
that's responsible for a news agency to
run a story with zero evidence or
corroboration
even though there's there's more
evidence and you could read in a
lifetime corroborating Brett Kavanaugh
story provided way more evidence than
Ford did right so the FB when you talk
about the authorities and they said well
no hon a second this is not consistent
right you have plenty of arguments that
will grow but it factually do you think
it's responsible for a news agency to go
out and carry a story especially when
the other rape accusations like Julie
sweat Nick I came or the other person
were verifiably false they started
running them than they would held them
you think that's responsible for a news
agency to do that sets the precedent
that anyone can come out and accuse
anyone of rape so long as it was long
enough ago no proof that's dangerous
Jimmy brothers David dad what if someone
came out and did that to your dad and
seen and amplified it as though it were
true with no proof at all
I thought I do think that especially men
it is sorry at a high risk of being
falsely accused of assault and
especially sexual assault right and I
think that that is terrifying
but I think that people should have the
freedom to say what they want to say I'm
having the freedom to say what they want
to say this again say what she wants
example of CNN amplifying a story that
was verifiably false after with no
evidence at all oh no if it was
verifiably false so guilty until proven
innocent no evidence needed guilty until
proven innocent but being guilty
illegally is different than being guilty
in the public domain just having your
name reputation ruined forever as long
as we disagree with you politically
that's okay to do which is what CNN did
there I you seem like a sharp enough
girl you understand that that's very
dangerous someone coming forward saying
I was raped decades ago I have no proof
whatsoever he has a journal
he has dates he has pay stubs he there's
plenty of evidence to the contrary you
do understand the danger in having a
news network like CNN amplifying that to
block a Supreme Court pick with zero he
can't I mean that's dangerous that's so
dangerous
I think that you know I'm from
Connecticut okay and we had a case I
believe a few years ago is it's it was
in the recent past
where to I believe football players in
college they were accused of rape by
another college student and they were
found guilty and okay she came out later
and met I thought she made it up and
only did so so that her ex-boyfriend or
her boyfriend wouldn't be mad at her or
leave her something along those lines
and the do you guys are traumatized
obviously
prison they were probably raped himself
they lost their scholarships and of
course that's damaging for them and
completely unfair and illegal I think
that is Alyssa that's terrible but
that's different than I heard it's
solely claiming something and both are
terrible well let's take a test exact
same story I didn't go to prison it's
not live where's the poison go to prison
must've been one of those educational
tribunals that otherwise I would have
grown a prison for rape but take that
girl mix it up right only switch out the
tribunal or whatever that was foreseen
at one of the biggest news networks in
the world and they amplified it doesn't
matter if those boys versus their lives
over so you see the you see the danger
in irresponsibility I do think it's
dangerous and I do think false
accusations are terrible and I think if
you can prove that they're false then
you should be given the same punishment
why is it you're done to present their
false
innocent till proven guilty you're
familiar with our legal system right so
you believe if someone accuses someone
else of rape or a crime it's my job to
prove that I didn't commit that crime
it's not your job to prove that I
committed the crime
well if right now I say you you beat my
puppy no good cause it's your job to
prove that you didn't cuz I might have
to prove that you did
there's I have a much bigger platform
and you do I can edit this any way I
want and I can take it out to the world
and say that you beat my dog for no
reason I have a lot of fans in my back
you think it's your job for me really
scary wouldn't it it would be you think
it's your job to prove that you didn't
or is it my job to prove that he did I'm
from a communist country and can I guess
I guess alright can I'm pretty good at
this uh Bailey ocean ocean no not need
to me not Vietnamese Cambodian no hi
yeah no I'm Chinese Filipino but I am
from a Chinese orphanage okay and as you
know China is very communist you've
hardly heard of the Hong Kong riots yes
and so the freedom of speech and the
freedom to live
is very very important to me
so how I view somebody falsely accusing
somebody else without evidence to me as
terrible as it is I'd rather be you know
a falsely accused by you of beating your
dog than having to be in a Hong Kong
riot so that's just how I see it
but that's not the point is that's not
what you have to endure you have the
same freedom here as anybody else that
and you have the same god-given any
label right of being assumed innocent
until proven guilty
it's not an either/or and that's what's
wonderful about this country and I would
hope that you continue to learn that and
continue to experience that because I
would hate for you to ever be called a
fuse and have your life through how they
free to be falsely accused of abuse and
lose your children someday that also
happens sometimes so yeah that sounds
like it sounds like we agree on a lot I
think we probably agree on this I bet
you if we were to talk six months from
now we probably would agree on more than
we even agree today that's most and
maybe Christine Christie thank you very
much Christie I appreciate it thank you
oh there you go I think Christine and I
agree on more than she thinks remember
if you want to support change my mind
joined mud at louder with CARICOM slash
mud club it's really the only way to
guarantee that these episodes continue
and you get access to hours of exclusive
content every week not available on
YouTube that's louder with Crowder com
slash mud club now on to Lucy who even
though she was a conservative claimed to
disagree with our premise and so we
thought a productive thought exercise
was an order oh you don't just run your
name tag correct decoratively
okay Democrat Republican oh really okay
well then you tell me I disagree I do
disagree I think it's really bad
precedent to set that we think the major
news publication that disagrees with our
president we label them as fake news we
don't listen to the other side I think
it's really detrimental to a country
where you block freedom of the press
from disagreeing with the president I
think if every outlet was like Fox News
and really liked the president or just
conservative criticism of the president
it would be bad for our democracy I
think it would be it's better to have
these disagreeing publications so that
we hear this other side
I completely agree with everything
you've just said I don't disagree with
any of it right that's why I think
calling them fake news is a bad thing
but they are fake news how are they fake
news they fabricate news they make it up
a lie like what well I don't have here
the examples I just listened for a
friend sorry guys you've all heard this
but I have to go back through it alright
well we obviously have the fusion GPS
steal dossier which was paid for by
Hillary Clinton in the DNC which they
didn't disclose we have the fact that
Donald Trump said that James Comey told
me wasn't being investigated CNN called
him a liar repeatedly turns out James
Comey did say that three times we have
the fake Russia story where they said
that Donald Trump knew in advance about
the Trump Tower meetings they said that
their source was anonymous and Lonny
Davis declined to comment
turned out Lonny Davis was their source
and they had to retract that Anthony
spero Moochie was an example with Russia
they said he was under investigation
that was wrong we had to retract that
the idea that he received information on
WikiLeaks before anyone else did that
was false it turned out already public
information they had to retract that CNN
was the first one to push and cover the
story this idea that Donald Trump
condemn white supremacists and Nazis in
Charlotte school where is he outright
did they had to fix that so I mean these
are issues that they've flat-out
fabricated I agree I think everyone
should be able I don't have a problem I
don't necessarily think it's fabrication
either I think when a new source is like
a big breaking news source right they
come out with things that they aren't
100% sure about they get tips on things
they're not sure about they published
what they kind of fits their narrative a
little bit I think Fox News would wait
longer to publish something that maybe
was detrimental to the president before
publishing it right away but go really
quick and jump on things that supported
the present well no but I'm talking
about fabricating stories out of thin
air but a lot of those things that you
said it seems like they didn't know and
then when they did find out or they got
hold on it and they retracted it okay
well let me walk you through one of them
because I just listed a bunch of
examples but here's why so how do you go
through for example saying Donald Trump
knew about the Trump Tower meetings
beforehand right and you're being fed
this by Lanny Davis
okay and say it comes from an anonymous
source and then put in your story that
Lanny Davis declined to comment when he
is your source he is the person who was
the source for the story you are
proactively citing an anonymous source
that you know to be Lanny Davis you said
isn't commenting on the story what I
mean there's a lot of there's a lot of
that goes into like protecting witnesses
to stories and stuff like that so I
think that's like a certain it was
completely unsubstantiated and they
mentioned when he was in the story like
Larry Davis by the way refused to
comment well who gave me the story
anonymous you mean Lana Davis they
didn't cite that he was the person that
gave him the name no they said it was
anonymous and then they said by the way
Lanny Davis to climb to comment it was
Lonny Davis was really he was a sort I
understand protecting an anonymity
though well not when it's always
anonymous now when it's Donald Trump's
pissing on Russian prostitutes anonymous
not when it's well this Russia collusion
which we know if you work on the
Republican is proven to be one of the
biggest hoaxes of all time constantly
proven false proven false having to
retract it people having to resign and
disgrace and the problem here now is it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you
have people out there 40 percent of
Americans who believe that Donald Trump
colluded with Russia when we know
definitively that he didn't I mean
that's an issue how do they not
accidentally get stories wrong on the
other side how is it always accidentally
wrong and something that only they know
about cuz no sure never retracted
anything and they never know of course
they have this is what
breaking news outlets have to do with
this is what they do they release things
too early and then they have to retract
and I think that there is maybe a bias
in CNN that goes there definitely is a
bias that goes to the left in semen but
the same thing is true on the right and
the same problems happen on the right I
think you could just as easily stand out
here with Fox News or Fox News as fake
news or something like that
I don't think so I really I really don't
think so I don't have a problem with
someone who's far left and promoting in
his opinion I don't promise someone
who's far right so for example I have
the same problem with Tucker Carlson
Sean Hannity they had with Rachel Maddow
and chris matthews and lawrence
o'donnell which is none i have no
problem with any of them i have a
problem with people who present
themselves as though they are the
arbiters of news or objectivity and
that's what CNN has done for a very long
time that's my issue with them any news
is slogan until last year was fair and
balan the radio set and by the way their
news though their news is significantly
more fair and balanced there's anyone's
been the opinion side so for example
[ __ ] dude is really clear and separating
the bill o'reilly sean hannity's across
into the world from say you know Shep
Smith you just Center leftist gay guys
right or Judge Napolitano whose high
heart libertarian you know they have
Donna Brazile over there now where's
when you look at the host it's seen in
Don Lemon you look at Anderson Cooper
you look at Chris Cuomo for crying out
loud and they presented as though it's
news that's my issue and it is to me
always remarkable that the stories that
okay we can say fabrication occurs in
any news network always seems to tar and
feather and be an attempt to undermine
the legitimacy of our sitting president
I mean you do have to acknowledge that
when they get it wrong they always get
it wrong in a way that if it's stuck
would be very harmful to the president
yeah definitely but I think that an
important thing to notice about all
those examples that you did and those
are good examples that you should be
pointing out that they've attracted them
thought they did their best to go
against and say oh this was wrong I
think that undermines them being they
didn't until they were caught they
didn't until they were caught that's how
most people function I'm most news well
I don't okay fine but I don't give them
credit I don't give anyone credit for
once they're caught having to sure I
think attraction is plenty credit but I
also because Fox News I'm sure has had
retractions but they've had to wait for
people to call out sure I think a lot
they got a lot of things about Benghazi
a little bit off they had to retract
but a little bit off the brian Stelter
because entire shell was russia right
come on you on this same and their
entire line it was russia which was
awful there was all things that we
didn't know about russia that it was
good that there was but it's agency
looking into or just speculating that's
a good thing just if someone says i'm
speculating fine but if someone says
we're delivering the news that's a
problem like jesse smaller the face ed
we're speculating that's not what brian
Stelter and Brooke Baldwin went out and
did they talk about it being this
horrendous hate crime that this is a
sign of rising hate crimes across the
United States of America after the Jesse
Smollett hoax was revealed brian Stelter
said well I guess we'll never know what
happened that fateful evening like my
issue here is when you do have obviously
reason the term fake news because
President Trump uses it but they fight
back and say we're legitimate news I
think that they do do things I think
they have a legitimate purpose in our
democracy that's why I don't think I
think they get a lot of things wrong and
I think it's great that you are calling
them out or that people on the right are
calling them out but I just think
calling them fake news and that's what I
wanna know what your end goal is of
calling them fake news is it to get them
not watch is it to get them shut down is
it to get President Trump to do
something turns no and that's a very
fair question as a matter of fact anyone
here who watches my show they know that
I say bookmark Huffington Post salon
slate CNN that's all I read I tell
people always know what the opposition
is telling you you should be informed
but I include CNN among that group I
include CNN among a left-wing activist
group not news especially by the way
when they're trying to shut down other
news channels especially by the way when
they're trying to shut down YouTube
independent YouTube channels and they
have used the systems with false
copyrights and they by the way are the
ones who coined the term fake news
trying to talk about Republicans right I
had been hit with the fake news moniker
for something was entirely accurate this
is actually at will not remember fake
news was a term invented by the left and
then Donald Trump said okay well you
want to talk about fake news and went
down just went through the laundry list
of all the fake fabrications from CNN so
my problem is not with someone being
left my problem is now but being
dishonest about it and that's what I
think is a problem and I just think it's
hard to categorize CNN as this as this
whole I mean I've watched you know CN in
foreign affairs for a long
time or you know the shows that they do
abroad they cover topics in the Middle
East and in Africa that a lot of places
don't cover that a lot of people don't
have so CNN American politics is such a
small component of this large network
that I think does a lot of good research
and good reporting that's not a small
component though it's the majority of
their cup I think it's a majority of
maybe what people focus here but CNN is
viewed worldwide it's watched worldwide
it's it has people worldwide so I'm I
mean I know like at school where
sometimes made to watch CNN 10:00 every
morning but they do cover valuable news
well there are some valuable news but
the point is everyone everyone can bring
some value to the table but you do have
to look at a risk for reward ratio and
I'm not saying eliminate them but I do
think that it is important to
definitively when you have an
organization that is one of the top 10
donors Hillary Clinton when they're
feeding questions to Hillary Clinton
from the DNC when they are actively
seeking donna Brazile to bed okay well
I've done it several times I've actually
were asking questions from the DNC
script this isn't the journalist and I'm
gonna remember that Andrew Breitbart
used to cover when Andrew Breitbart was
alive not bright part to site bright
part the man went back to Dave Weigel
and all of these four people I think as
recline it's an issue it's an issue I
just I appreciate that you want as many
sources of news as possible and open
points of view I totally agree with that
I wish that CNN felt the same way I wish
they weren't trying to silence voices of
dissent either through actual legal
measures if they take it through new
media or through trying to tar and
feather feather Bonilla disagree with
has a racist or sexist or homophobic
but I just would like them to be honest
about the fact that they are political
activists agree with that I just think
fake news is such a harsh label that has
been used to quash freedom of the press
for so long but it was used against
Donald it was used against Republicans
and Donald Trump in concern just because
of his use against us doesn't make it
okay and doesn't mean when we call it
out as wrong we don't get to turn around
and use it on other I think it's
appropriate nothing no I think they can
do it I think they can do it but I think
it's appropriate to use it against them
because I think there was a long time in
this country where people thought that
Walter Cronkite was my god an actual
journalist and he said he can't be a
journalist and not be a liberal
I mean you look at you look at the long
history of it I think they've always
been very far left and now people are
just able to call it be an activist
journalist who doesn't you know any
journalist doesn't imply that you're not
- aside well if someone says that if
Chris Cole were to come out and say
listen my family basically runs this
party in this on the eastern seaboard
right and I am pushing an agenda but I
said he comes out and says no I'm just
asking the questions I'm News Bill
O'Reilly for a long time said you know
no spin zone this is a very you know I
take things as they are I address them
you know from an unbiased perspective I
never like to go around holding anyone
did but I always said Bill O'Reilly was
disingenuous with that I always listened
Bill O'Reilly can do one fake news did
you say all the Fox News is well no
because bill OH bill o'reilly was a
pending bill o'reilly came from inside
edition right it's very different to
have journalists to have anchors people
who proclaim themselves to be
journalists how the people I think who
were involved with the I can't weather
was a Lanny Davis story or it might have
been the WikiLeaks story one of them was
a Pulitzer winner
turns out they completely fabricated
this stuff my point is I mean my school
gives up bullet I mean we know the the
super biased process like okay well you
understand that yeah no I think that it
was jujitsu time turned on the left and
I think that it's appropriate and they
made there better needle iana but I
would never seek to ban them or silence
their points of view I tell everyone
here watch them as much as you can so
that you know exactly what you're
getting so that's this label fake news
gonna do for the Conservatives why is
them accepting this label or saying you
know what we're fake news we don't like
well that's a good question I think for
the longest time you know for example
this is not a trick question you're
probably not familiar with journalists
right journalist was a big thing that
happened Andrew Breitbart covered okay
well I wanted to be range of food right
to ask woman your range but you look for
you okay and it never really stuck and
the reason it never really stuck is
because it was very wonky
it was one of those things you had to
kind of do a deep dive to understand
what was going on but there is something
that we've inherently known for a long
time which was a far left as bias in the
news and then when these people have
sought to undermine the president and
not just this president they did it with
george w bush they did it with anyone
who ran for president by the way when
they seek to undermine and they're
somewhat successful giving it a names
but people understand this isn't over
you
is fake this is not real reporting for
example I think it 48% of Americans who
still believe the Russia hoax you need
to cut through that and if you say well
oh I got this wrong they got this wrong
they got this right no it's fake news
fabricated there's no evidence that's an
odd stat to bring up though if 48
percent because they've estimated that
about 50 percent of Americans have
actually read portions are all of the
molar report so even having that come
out I don't know how you could see CNN
bias on that people have read this
report and on its face value they've
come away with many of them have come
away but most people have not read the
full report not even close people can
say they've read some portions of the
report and again if you look at that
polling it's very subjective they feel
that reading the report for example has
been watching what CNN has aired or what
they read on BuzzFeed no I very much
doubt that people write a full four
hundred page report didn't say that in
the polling question people feel that
way because they believe a lot of issues
for example they believe that Donald
Trump met with Putin they believe that
Michael Cohen went to went to croc which
as we know is not true they believe that
WikiLeaks symptom when you look at the
individual issues they believe fake
stories that came from CNN and by the
way all of this info stems from the
steal dossier from chief using GPS paid
for by the DNC and Hillary Clinton they
don't know that so people believe this
the Russia hoax because of the messaging
that's seen and not just CNN but
everyone at ABC NBC CBS CNN MSNBC we're
pushing for a long time that we're
verifiably false that's my issue right
that's dangerous yeah III think they
have the right to do it if they're
labeled opinion and this is us combating
bad information with better information
I think that's totally fair I think you
know but I just I still fear that label
and I fear it used I was used against
Fox News fo news for the longest time
right and that was dangerous too and
just because you don't agree with
someone's political opinion I just think
the fake news it's not because I wonder
what their political thing you don't
frame it that way that's not right Bart
had as many of these errors I don't
think you would sit outside Breitbart
headquarters and say Breitbart is fake
news probably not but I have said the
bright bar is not a legitimate news
organization since Andrews died but my
issue is not that I disagree with and
politically my issue that they fabricate
stories but I'm saying that the
dichotomy between CNN and Breitbart
which you've both represent opinion wait
a minute
I mean it's not always marketed that way
they do they do have a new section they
have a new section but Breitbart you
know exactly what you're getting
CNN still tries well no that's all thing
for the longest time until people
realize they were fake news up until
this last election they thought that CNN
was my god journalism remember was a
shock when Candy Crowley tried to a
sideswipe Mitt Romney remember every was
like how well how could she do that and
I remember back thing because it's CNN
people didn't know now they know okay so
no I appreciate thank you so much I
appreciate it Lucy everybody there
YouTube you if you liked this
installment I've changed my mind click
on one of these other installments
playing in a box it's the only way you
can find it because if you search it it
may not show up because it's
controversial and in YouTube wants to UM
discourage that the controversy to
change my mind playing by the rules we
just don't know what they are
subscribing to notifications